you've said something about
gravity sort of uh that you don't need
to explicitly inject anything into the
system they can be learned from the data
and gravity is an example of something
that could be learned from data
so like the physics of the world like
what what are the limits of what we can
learn from data
do you really do you think we can so a
very simple clean way to ask that is do
you really think we can learn gravity
from just data the idea the the laws of
gravity
so something that i think is is a common
um
kind of pitfall when thinking about
prior knowledge and learning
is to assume that just because
we know something then that it's better
to tell the machine about that rather
than have it figure it out on its own
in many cases things that are
important that affect many of the events
that the machine will experience
are actually pretty easy to learn like
you know if things
if every time you drop something it
falls down like yeah you might not get
the
you know you might get kind of the
newton's version not einstein's version
but it'll be pretty good and it will
probably be sufficient for you to act
rationally in the world
because you see the phenomena all the
time so things that are
readily apparent from the data we might
not need to specify those by hand it
might actually be easier to let the
machine figure them out
it just feels like that there might be a
space of many local
local minima in terms of theories of
this world that we would
discover and get stuck on yeah of course
newtonian
mechanics is not necessarily easy to
come by
yeah and well in fact uh in in some
fields of science for example human
civilizations itself full of these local
optima so for example if you
uh think about how people uh try to
figure out uh biology and medicine you
know for the longest time
the kind of rules like the kind of uh
principles that serve us very well in
our day-to-day lives actually serve us
very poorly
in understanding uh medicine and biology
we had kind of very
uh superstitious and weird ideas about
how the body worked until the advent of
the modern scientific method
so that does seem to be you know a
failing of this approach but it's also a
failing of human intelligence arguably
you